it was a real pinch me moment from we're
all waiting nervously to go on stage and
you can just hear people cheering and
actually what hits you is the affection
the warmth that was coming from the
audience today for for the for the
franchise and for those characters and
and actually it's just been such a such
a wonderful experience it really really
has you can't help but be touched by
those characters and and you you have
such empathy for them and and you invest
in them and I hope that in ro1 we do the
same you feel the same when you watch it
it's called the opening crawl exactly so
it's a group of unlikely heroes who band
together steal the plans to the Death
Star it was the first time that people
had seen some of the behind the scenes
footage which is absolutely incredibly
shards and and and gave people I think
an impression of how we've been working
and the and the authenticity that we've
been wanting to get in the film and
trying to make it feel as immersive as
possible and and and when you watch it
you're really rooting for those
characters and and you want them to
succeed and but you're there with them
in those battles that's what that's what
we hope people will feel being in front
of such true diehard Star Wars fans and
unveiling rogue one yes it's pretty
special I mean there's a lot there's a
lot of love for the entire series in
that in that room it's pretty good you
don't get many better audiences in now
you walk out there and there's a moment
with where the crowds like going where
and then they see and they sort of lock
on and then people just stand and they
just start cheering and then you walk
along and there's people taking
photographs in front of you is keep
moving through them you go up the stairs
and people are people are pretty excited
what you really know about in that room
is the degree of love
for the for the films and the amount
that they're connected to it I've been
to a lot of conventions before a lot of
cons before but never one that was
specific to one universe and that was so
big I mean that's it's a lot of Star
Wars fans in one place and when you're
the next movie coming out there's a lot
of energy focused on you and your
project so it's exciting it's infectious
to have all that excitement I mean we're
excited to see each other again you know
it's been a little while for us all to
come back together and then also for us
to see some of the movie as well because
we haven't seen the polished part of
this movie scenes you know what we were
seeing on set but there's so many pieces
coming together as you could see in the
behind the scenes footage that seeing it
put together with all of the elements is
nice I was probably a little too young
to go to see Star Wars and the movie
theater but I did and then Empire
Strikes Back and Return of the Jedi
there was just the best movies they were
you couldn't miss them they were as you
wouldn't miss these you know they're
they're important k2s oh is a droid he
was a former security droid for the
Empire and he was reprogrammed by
casseon who is diego luna's character
and captain Endor and and so he is his
droid and he is devoted to cassia it's
been an exciting day I mean I've been
waiting for this quite a long time he
was the energy and that
unbelievable you know I've never I've
never done a project that people is
expecting so much you know that feeling
of like oh my god they really want this
out you know and and I was sharing the
feeling because I didn't see that piece
till today you know so I was also very
excited to watch it it's been a year of
secrecy you know being able to talk not
even to your best friends or family and
finally we're allowed to talk and to
start sharing this is amazing journey
which is go through and hoping that the
film does great you know and that it
pays back all that love that we are
receiving we are family so it felt great
to be all of us there normally press is
about you going there and talking and
that's it and this time it was the team
the family and those who were not on
stage we're down there you know I could
see the DP the producers it was it was
an amazing celebration it's very rare
that you do something that matters so
much for so many you know and and that
also connects me with my childhood you
know it connects me with my love for
cinema you know comes out of any hope
and my journey through him through the
Star Wars world you know so I don't know
I'm a fan to think you know and that you
are as excited as as those who are
sitting down I was born in 79 so and I
was like the young cousin you know in
the gang of you know my family so there
was this thing of wanting to belong you
know till to what my older cousins were
talking about and I jumped into the
world of Star Wars to be part of that
you know so I felt connected to that kid
I was you know today and and I felt
again that excitement it's the most
grounded film of Star Wars I think you
know this is the film about the people
you know this is the film about rebels
you know doing something and and and
there's like just there is the belief
for the force but we're not Jedi's we
are we are rebels and we're fighting for
freedom this is very rewarding as an
actor and as a as a fan you know seeing
that we solved today on stage and seen
the response from all the fans and I
can't wait to see the movie it's funny
you know I'm looking at him as like I'm
looking at a kid you know in a candy
store
every single day and walking through all
of us all the cast you know with I mean
I remember gala thing walking us through
the scene and humming the beat this is
so funny looking at this director this
young man that you can see that kind of
child love and passion pouring out of
his body
it was quite inspiring for me as an
actor to see a director you know you get
motivated by director having that kind
of passion my eight years old son is
stressed in current current outfit for
well fit with the lightsaber so you know
so they're just having a having a ball
I love the fence and I love the people
we work together
I like the atmosphere I'm lucky I feel
happy I'm a part of Star Wars you feel
that energy when you first walk me
because we were walking in and we could
hear the audience in there clapping
what's going on out there well what are
they showing them why they started you
know it's so intense they've already
must be watching something you know and
then when you go and you watch the
audience from backstage you kind of get
the feel but until you walk out on the
stage you feel like these four thousand
some other people being so supportive I
think you can understand it till then I
think some of the behind the scenes
stuff that they show was so intense and
impassioned you know it's uh it's really
exciting to see actually just for myself
and I watch that I was like I was like
caught by it's very emotional it's very
intense it's the way it's shot the way
the ways you know structured the music
they use really really grabs you I think
the audience really was taken by them
this is my first exposure to a
Stallworth celebration and you know it's
told how supportive and enthusiastic the
fans would be but yeah I can't tell you
how much it means to all of us because
we've been kind of hold away in studios
and bunkers and in strange locations and
cockpits of space shuttles kind of doing
this thing almost with cabin fever and
then to come out and then reconnect with
the actual fans the people who keep it
alive is incredible one of the things
it's just special about the Star Wars
movies is the suspense and the
anticipation that accompanies it you
know what new parts of this incredibly
rich story world will be revealed and so
we want to try and kind of you know tell
people enough but not too much we've
been kind of working really hard on this
trying to make this film as good as it
can possibly be you know try and really
just for the fans to try and make sure
that they're happy with something that
means so much to them and so to kind of
show little bits of the film here and
see that reaction it's a massive sigh
relief and it's also a massive injection
of excitement for us what they showed
today was behind the scenes clip a kind
of sizzle reel of lots of exciting
sequences from the film but shown from
the perspective of a kind of making of
so you know it's the fans that really
makes thought was really
and so I think everybody Lucasfilm felt
was important to try and just let them
into even the making of this you know
because we don't make this alone the
fans make it to they make it what it is
it's pretty surreal if I wasn't on the
stage I'd be paying money to be in the
crowd it was my I'm massive Star Wars
fan it's where I was was made you know
the original trilogy was shot in London
and you know force awakens was London
Weyland and so it's the home as far as
I'm concerned of Star Wars if you tell
me as a kid like 40 years from now are
you gonna get to make movies when they
go guess what movie star wars I just
don't think I would have believed it
would have been it's all very surreal
every day is to rely Star Wars
you